he's extremely jealous of my brother and  I success because my brother and I  Success is Not based on the same  successes that he enjoyed his success is  based on being a clown that's why he has  viewers he puts on a Pokemon suit and he  jumps around like a clown he doesn't sit  there and give ideas or say things that  make people think to the point where  they genuinely resonate with your  mindset he's not intelligent enough of  that he's a performing clown as opposed  to a philosopher so they're different  opposite things and he knows that and it  upsets him he can't sit in front of a  camera by himself and say words that are  going to inspire the crowds of of any  city in the world to shout to shout your  name if I were to walk through Madrid  right now there would be young people  shouting my name top Gene top cheating  that's because of what I say he puts on  a Pokemon suit and does a dance he's an  Entertainer he's not a thinker